[Musique]
le proverbe les voyages forment la
jeunesse reflète bien notre monde
aujourd'hui où ces 10 % de la population
mondiale qui voyagent 10% des étudiants
pardon donc il ya bien en effet des
millions d'étudiants qui voyagent pour
différentes raisons
certains cherchent à vivre une
expérience unique ou bien alors certains
cherchent à rencontrer des balles
culture qui casse les codes de leurs
habitudes en outre nous cherchons à
sortir de notre bulle donc nous allons
nous intéresser à qu'est ce qui pousse
les étudiants après leur bac à voyager
pourquoi voyager et qu'est ce que cela
leur apporte donc nous allons étudier
l'amérique qui le pays qui accueille le
plus d'étudiants au monde
chaque année depuis quelques années avec
le prix du low cost et les avions qui
sont donc moins cher et l'ouverture des
frontières les pays veulent faire venir
des étudiants pour exporter leurs
cultures et donc ceci va faire qu'on
voit de plus en plus d'étudiants voyager
dans le monde les jeunes voyage car cela
chamboule leurs habitudes leur manière
de vivre et leur apprend des choses des
techniques qu'une fois le retour ils
pourront utiliser à l'amérique la
première puissance économique et ses
belles universités dont 17 dans les
meilleurs du monde et la première qui
est tabac je pense que vous la
connaissez tous donc l'amérique se
distingue par sa pédagogie par cpd par
sa pédagogie qui est basée sur
l'autonomie et la réflexion est plus sur
la sur la compréhension que sur la sur
la l'accumulation de connaissances à peu
près
apprises bien que c est qu bien que ses
études sa coûteuse
on peut y arriver grâce au mérite avec
une bourse scolaire qui ne sera donnée
en fonction de leurs résultats scolaires
il ay ay la fin longtemps encore j'étais
j'étais jeune mais je suis un étudiant
vous allez me dire maintenant mais
depuis que je suis tout petit je vois le
monde change et il est encore longtemps
voyagé et est exclusivement réservé aux
riches
mais désormais tout le monde peut y
arriver donc si maintenant vous voulez
vous voulez a étudié en amérique dans la
meilleure université à à new york
l'université de columbia et bien
travailler votre étudié à l'école et
vous réaliserez votre futur à merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]